this week
on brian ross investigates the mystery
woman who once served as
jeffrey epstein's pilot i think she's an
extremely important witness
but before she was a pilot witnesses say
she was a teenage sex slave for epstein
and then helped to recruit other young
women for the multi-millionaire sex
predator
who took his own life while awaiting
trial do you in the end have sympathy
for her
you know it's a mixed if that that's a
mixed question i have sympathy for her
yes
plus growing concern about president
trump's claim
that a covet 19 vaccine will be
available
before the november election it will
produce a vaccine before the end of the
year
or maybe even sooner we'll talk with the
top public health official
dr boris lushniak what's the latest
what's the truth in the united states
and
this week's winners and losers in the
media see if you agree with the editors
of
media they choke just like in a golf
tournament
they miss a three foot they're not
comparing it to golf
from the lawn crime trial network this
is brian ross investigates
evening and welcome i'm brian ross
joined tonight as always by my colleague
at the law and crime network
rhonda schwartz and rhonda we begin with
someone described as a mystery woman in
the case of jeffrey epstein
the multi-millionaire sex predator he
took his own life while awaiting trial
in new york but the fbi investigation of
his activities does continue rhonda
that's right and last july the fbi
arrested epstein's close associate
gelaine maxwell
she's being held in federal custody
she's pleaded not guilty to charges of
child sex trafficking
but the fbi is continuing their
investigation and looking at other close
epstein associates
including prince andrew who of course
has denied any allegations of sexual
impropriety with minors
and of course the fbi is looking for
important witnesses one of them could be
the woman by the name of nadia martinko
she is a former pilot for jeffrey
epstein
and we're going to learn a lot about her
fascinating backstory
from a journalist who's been covering
this story christine negroni who is a
aviation journalist who worked for the
new york times seen on abc news
and has her own blog christine told us
all about when i talked to her earlier
the story of nadia marchenko
so who is nadia marchenko
well nadia martenko was one of the
unindicted co-conspirators in the first
criminal action brought against jeffrey
epstein back in the mid 2000s
and she was in in the indictment she was
both victim of jeffrey epstein
she had in the indictment they they
called her a
quote a a sex slave
of jeffrey epstein but in the complaints
filed by the young women
in palm beach in west palm beach she was
an active participant in some of the
sex acts perpetrated against them so
she's a complicated
figure in the jeffrey epstein story but
she is also
a long-standing figure in the jeffrey
epstein story
and now you are reporting that she's
become quite the accomplished pilot
well i don't know how accomplished she
is as a pilot but she certainly made a
reputation
as a celebrity pilot so she got
her she got her pilot's license right
around the time that jeffrey epstein was
serving time
the first time in um in florida and she
went
on to some very fairly quickly some
uh some considerably responsible jobs
as a first officer or co-pilot on
jeffrey epstein's airplanes for example
and then when i met her in late 2013
she told me that she was flying an
embryo phenom
300 which is a nice expensive
uh high-powered jet um that many
business people use and there there are
lots of documents that say that um
when when the authorities wanted to
question her
jeffrey epstein blew her out of the
country
so she could avoid being forced to
testify
once she became an unindicted
co-conspirator and once the she was
granted that
sweeping immunity that of course has
made all the news
then she didn't have to testify about
anything anymore because
she was given immunity so now as the fbi
continues to investigate what was left
in the wake of jeffrey epstein and his
suicide and the arrest of
just lane maxwell she could be an
important witness i take it
i think she's an extremely important
witness what she knows
uh she you know she was in the in the
epstein compound for
many many years starting off at 14 if
though
you know if the documents are to be
believed um
she would have been well acquainted with
many many of the women who have brought
complaints against jeffrey epstein she
would obviously know
galen maxwell and then of course the
interesting point
to me recently of course is delaine
maxwell wound up fleeing to sanctuary in
new hampshire
and nadia martinko spent a good deal of
her post
epstein residents in new hampshire as
well
and so that you know sort of begs the
question of
whether there are other uh people whose
names have not yet previously been
linked to epstein
who maybe should get some attention and
nadia marchenko's the woman to do it
she's got a lot at stake here she has
not been criminally charged
for the second time as galaine maxwell
has been
um will that immunity hold up can
politically speaking anyone bring
charges against her
considering the fact that she was so
young when she was brought into jeffrey
epstein's orbit
you discovered this video in which nadia
appears to be part of a prank on a pilot
in california what's that all about
well you know it i i described it in my
blog post as being sort of a microcosm
of her life
she gets into this uh acrobatic airplane
and
she sits in the back and the pilot's
taking her around she's dressed like a
little girl she's got
big tails or braids and you know sort of
this ill-fitting outfit and
and they take off and then halfway
through the flight he says well you want
to give it a try
okay
so she takes over the airplane and
darned if she's not you know like a
superstar aviator and she does all her
tricks and he's you know
so surprised
she rips off the little girl outfit and
there she is all busty in a
tight black dress pulls off you know
when her beautiful blonde hair comes out
and it's like
you know i'm i'm i'm a sex part pilot
you know and that's her whole
identity her whole public identity is
that
which you could you could kind of laugh
at if it weren't so tragic
because that's really her the little
girl
who was turned into due to her
association with
jeffrey epstein turned into a to an
adult woman who believes her only value
is as a as an attractive baboon girl
and that you know that's sort of sad and
and anyone associated with her who
allows her to continue that i think does
her no
service and at the end of the day is
there sympathy for her she was brought
into epstein's circle
as a young teenager became a sex slave
became a victim now a survivor of this
uh what happened next what happened but
uh
do you in the end have sympathy for her
you know it's a mixed if that that's a
mixed question i have sympathy for her
yes
but i find what happens when i write
about her and i've written a lot about
her
especially recently with her connection
in new hampshire
i find that people usually come down
along the the lines of she should you
know she should rot in hell
she should go to jail so i find that
there's an awful lot of anger
foisted at nadia that really
is not voiced on the right entity she
was
a victim if she was also a victimizer
and
it looks likely that she was you must
see that in the light of her youth
and her own abuse that's it
it's one hand in the other it's it's a
total package so yes
i feel sorry for her i i think if she's
doing a responsible thing and
sort of exposing that larger circle then
she's
making amends for you know for whatever
role she played in
in the persecution of other women
christine negroni thank you so much for
joining us tonight
thank you
we reached out to maria marchenko and
her lawyer for comment but so far no
response
coming up the race for the vaccine
against covid19
we'll talk with a top public health
official about what the truth is
beyond the hype you're watching the law
and crime trial network
this week as the covet 19 pandemic
continues schools are reopening
around the world from london to saint
petersburg to wuhan china where the
whole thing started
but in the us it's been a mixed vague as
the continued concern about the spread
of the virus
and rhonda the increasing death toll
the virus does rage on here in the u.s
with over
6 million cases and since march 183
000 deaths the numbers are almost so
large they're they're almost
incomprehensible
and today there's new reports that the
viruses cases are spiking in the midwest
indeed well joining us to talk about
this is dr boris lesniak he is the dean
of the
university of maryland school of public
health and was the acting surgeon
general during a good chunk of the obama
administration
dr lozniak thank you so much for joining
us thanks for having me brian
let me start by asking you big picture
do you see any uh bright uh
light at the end of the tunnel well big
picture
uh we're not exactly where we thought
we'd be at this point in time you know
there have been at least a hope that we
would run into a summer lull with ovid
19 and that we would be
expecting a surge coming up in the fall
and winter
what happened obviously was throughout
the summer time we never got to that low
and we have these sporadic hotspots as
you mentioned currently in the midwest i
think south dakota and iowa are two
states most affected right now but it's
really been spreading throughout the
united states and so therefore the
pandemic sort of moves on
unabated
last week at the republican convention
president trump promised there'd be a
vaccine by the end of the year
take a look at what he said i want to
ask you about what you think of what he
had to say
the entire planet has been struck by a
new
and powerful invisible enemy
like those brave americans before us we
are meeting this challenge
we are delivering life-saving therapies
and we'll produce a vaccine before the
end of the year
or maybe even sooner
dr lushnik presidential hype or is there
some truth in that do you think
well there's a lot of progress being
made on the vaccine front let's remember
that prior to december 31st 2019
which was why it's an important date
because that was the date that the who
office in china was informed of an
outbreak of
people with pneumonia due to an unknown
cause so we're now nine months into this
and in those nine months obviously this
has been a novel
virus that's been identified right and i
love using the word novel here because
it
really is both definitions novel is
brand new our immune system
is not used to it and secondly novel in
that it's been a page turner throughout
this whole process we keep learning
brand new things so
incredible progress in that in these
short nine months
we now have 36 different vaccine
candidates that are in human clinical
trials
yet i don't see it happening by the end
of the year in terms of having
an improved vaccine ready to go
uh there's still a lot of work to be
done ahead of us again
a lot of great progress right now we
have nine such vaccine candidates
in what's called phase three clinical
trial which is now thousands of people
getting the vaccine it's being looked at
from the perspective of does it work
phases one and phase two of vaccine
trials really look at safety measures
safety measures are still being
tabulated here but at the same time we
are finally at the point of seeing
whether things work or not
this has become the new space race
globally we know the russians have a
vaccine that they say is ready to go we
know the chinese are are continuing on
their vaccine front
and many other nations are involved but
i don't see it happening by the election
and i don't see it happening
by the end of the year perhaps early in
2021
will we be at a point where perhaps a
vaccine will be
proven to work but at the same time then
we have to get into
mass production of that vaccine and mass
distribution
dr question for you from rhonda schwartz
rhonda
it's the beginning of september the
classic back to school week
in some countries some cities schools
are reopening
but new york city due to the virus has
pushed back the
delayed the reopening of schools what do
you say about this what's your take on
this
well ronda again it's very difficult to
say let's just open up the schools
while we still have community spread of
the virus going on
right one of the main features of spread
of this virus is dealing with the
density
right of how many people do we have
close together
and i know a lot of the schools are
reopening and have taken into public
health recommendations right the whole
idea of physical distancing the mask
where the hand
washing that continues to be very very
important
and yet i'm concerned about this idea of
lots of people
gathering together this becomes risky
not only for potentially the students
themselves
that is spread between students but
certainly to the adults who are teaching
in those
classes and then the potential of
bringing it back home so this
has to be done very wisely and very
carefully it can't just be a cart launch
that we're opening the schools and we're
ready
doctor final question for you do you see
too much of the heavy hand of politics
and the decisions being made about this
absolutely you know the problem from the
get-go uh regarding the national
response
uh uh in fighting covet 19 and
fighting this is disastrous pandemic
has been that it's been hyped
politically all along like when did it
become sort of politics right to say
whether your mass wearing or not
i think the major mistake has been that
the health communication the public
health communication
began coming from political leadership
as opposed to
coming from public health leadership uh
and you know politicians need to be
involved they are elected leaders of our
society to be able to move us ahead
but the reality is communication needs
to be coming from the scientific base
side from the medical base side from the
public health based side
side and therefore i think it's become
very confusing for the american public
depending on who's saying what and who
they believe in
that shouldn't have happened
indeed dr boris lushnik from the
university of maryland school of public
health
thank you so much for being here tonight
great thank you so much
coming up this week's winners and losers
in the media
see if you agree with what the editors
of media have to say about
laura ingram you're watching the long
crime trial network
we continue now with this week's winners
and losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin
who's the editor-in-chief of meteorite
which like the law and crime trial
network is part of the dan abrams media
empire
aidan thanks so much for being here
let's start with your first winner
caitlyn collins of cnn who took
president trump to test yesterday at the
white house
over his support of people considered
who are involved in violence
but first you were just criticizing joe
biden saying he didn't mention the far
left or antifa during his speech today
you said you wanted to talk about
left-wing political violence
yeah but i noticed you did not mention
that your supporters were also in
portland this weekend
firing paintball guns at people some
form of pepper spray
so do you want to also take this chance
to condemn what your supporters did
so there's some tough questions there
for the president from caitlin collins
yeah she she you know caitlyn collins
she's cnn's white house correspondent
and
she's well known for questioning trump
uh from the briefing room
this was a particularly impressive
showing from caitlin collins
uh you know trump basically held this
press conference after
joe biden had criticized him uh for his
response to
the unrest across america now trump came
out
and gave a lengthy uh sort of address
where he
called out biden for not explicitly
condemning uh far-left protesters
um and some of the rioting that's
occurred across the country caitlyn
collins brought up the obvious point
that
you know president donald trump is
asking provide him to condemn farlow
protesters
uh which biden did to do to some extent
perhaps not by name as president trump
would have liked
but there were a lot of trump supporters
that were actually in these cities like
portland
there were videos that went viral of
trump supporters firing paintball
guns at protesters and letting out tear
gas
not to mention the trump supporter who
ended up uh
allegedly killing two people uh in
kenosha wisconsin
uh who's been charged with uh two
murders there so
she was questioning trump on that sort
of uh you know inconsistency in what he
was uh
saying from the podium there and
actually went on after
uh president donald trump sort of
dismissed her question uh he said that
you know
the paint or not bullets to ask about uh
kyle rittenhouse who is the suspected
shooter in kenosha
and trump moved on to another reporter
she protested and that other reporter
actually asked the question that caitlyn
collins had made
um and trump's answer made a lot of news
so it was a really strong showing from
the briefing room
you know that's kind of why we have
meteorite tune into these sessions to
get the sort of newsworthy moments
and information from the president
and to keep an eye on how reporters are
doing here's the sort of the exact
opposite
his interview uh yesterday with fox news
anchor laura ingram
listen to how this went down
they can do 10 000 great acts which is
what they do
and one bad apple or a choker you know a
joker they choke
shooting the guy shooting the guy in the
back many times i mean
couldn't you have done something
different couldn't you have wrestled
you know i mean in the meantime he might
have been going for a weapon and
you know there's a whole big thing there
but they choke
just like in a golf tournament they miss
a three foot
you're not comparing it to golf because
of course that's what the media i'm
saying people choke people
people choke
so it seems aiden laura ingram was
trying to save the president from
himself
yeah this was a pretty astonishing
interview you know i watch a lot of
these
uh president trump has been on fox news
dozens of times
for interviews with the likes of sean
hannity and those are typically
softball affairs uh laura ingram as we
know she's a primetime host at fox news
she's a fan of the president um so i
wasn't expecting to go into this you
know with tough questions
what was so astonishing about this
interview with trump is that laura
ingram repeatedly
corrected him or at least clarified what
he was saying
in order to rescue him from saying
something controversial um that is
probably the most
the clip you just played there was
probably the most viral of them uh when
she
she said you know you're not comparing a
police shooting
uh to a golfer uh you know choking at a
three-foot putt
which is exactly what he was doing um
but there were a few other examples
um of her basically saying you know
i hope you're not saying what i think
you're saying um you know at one point
he said that you know you can't build
low-income housing because then crime
will go up
she stepped in to say you're not saying
that poor people commit more crime
um of course that was the implication of
what he was saying uh he also said that
people are
controlling biden from the shadows which
was a sort of
weird and vague uh conspiracy theory she
actually stepped in to say
that sounds like a conspiracy theory
what are you talking about president
trump proceeded to say you know there
well there's these shadowy people in the
street that are controlling the street
that you don't know about that are
controlling biden and we're looking into
it
um you know it was good that laura
ingram asked what he was talking about
after he proceeded to to give a pretty
nonsensical explanation of what he was
talking about
she accepted it and moved on so those
were just three times in his one
interview where ingram had to try and
save the president from himself
it was a pretty odd affair and she's
acting more like a pr person than a
journalist frank
absolutely well very important to point
that out aidan so much thanks so much
for joining us tonight
and thanks to all you for joining us and
to our staff at long crime for getting
us
on the air and off the air
you